I thought but I didn't hear a story that  you were like up for the gov something  in The Godfather or like an extra or  something like that well yes I was up I  was  they needed 250 people basically 50 to  stand behind the wedding cake you don't  even see me and I was turned down by  Paramount who did Tulsa cake to be an  extra behind the cake and they said oh  you don't look Italian enough  the only thing that looked more Italian  to me is a pizza what is wrong with you  people my God I have spaghetti hanging  from my hair and 30 years later I hired  that casting agent for it to be an agent  I go how you doing is it true true you  hired the person for not being Italian  enough to be yeah that's right did you  tell them oh every day